el solo hecho de pensar o de escuchar la
palabra alzheimer nos causa inquietud o
cierta desazón y aunque no sabemos bien
de qué se trata
siempre podemos hacer una broma sobre
todo las gentes de mi edad cuando
olvidamos una cita y decimos estar
alcanzando el alemán sin embargo hay una
raíz de fondo según la organización
mundial de la salud
las cifras son impactantes hay más de 50
millones de personas en el mundo que
padecen la enfermedad y cada año se
agregan 10 millones de nuevos casos lo
que significa que cuando muchos de
ustedes estén en la edad de riesgo se
habrá incrementado enormemente la
población de enfermos sin que se
visualice una cura a corto plazo es un
mundo de gente
la enfermedad de alzheimer es quien se
lleva las palmas con entre el 60 y 70
por ciento los casos de demencia sin
embargo en mexico se agrega un factor
agravante muy importante la mayoría de
las personas mayores son muchas personas
mayores padecen hipertensión arterial y
diabetes mellitus si no pregúnteles a
sus abuelos
y eso significa la segunda parte de las
demencias importantes que es la demencia
vascular
la demencia es la principal causa de
discapacidad y dependencia entre las
personas mayores en todo el mundo y eso
tiene un impacto físico psicológico
social y económico en los cuidadores en
la familia y en la sociedad
las cifras son frías y tal vez no nos
dicen muchas veces las cosas pero todos
en la vida cotidiana hemos conocido
alguna persona mayor oa veces en la tele
una persona mayor perdida
que está un poco fuera de la realidad
que no conoce que olvida el nombre de
sus hijos que se pierde o que ya no sabe
hacer la comida que entre la silla
deliciosa
envejecer es el principal factor de
riesgo de la enfermedad de alzheimer es
decir que a los 60 años de edad el 5 por
ciento de las personas presentan
síntomas a los 70 años el 20 por ciento
y a los 80 más del 50 por ciento tienen
síntomas de alzheimer
en mi consultorio me enfrento a estos
problemas con frecuencia y es en general
los familiares directos los que acuden
con temor a consultar y practican
historias y dice que mi mamá si se
comporta mostrar últimamente que mi papá
estamos viendo algunas cosas y sobre
todo tiene un carácter que nadie lo
aguanta desde que se jubiló que mi
abuelita no me conoce y yo soy su nieto
favorito esas y otras preguntas hacen
que el familiar consulte con gran temor
de que se le diga la terrible palabra
alzheimer otros acuden con el
diagnóstico pero tienen miedo de saber
si a ellos les puede pasar lo mismo con
eso de la herencia en un 25% de los
casos hay un factor hereditario aunque
no se considera una enfermedad
hereditaria per se otros más acuden que
son la mayoría porque no saben qué hacer
con ellos no los entienden creen que los
están manipulando que los está engañando
que les está diciendo mentiras que
porque nada más los quiero tener aquí a
donde acudir que preguntar están
agotados están colapsados
todos estos procesos de temores tienen
un fundamento científico está ocurriendo
en que observamos nosotros también en la
consulta por lo que yo me enfrentado de
manera particular
son las emociones intensas mal manejadas
lo que hemos escuchado aquí sobre el
empoderamiento sobre los valores sobre
el amor sobre todo eso hay personas que
no tienen la capacidad de enfrentar las
situaciones críticas y el familiar te
dice desde que falleció mi papá mi mamá
ya no es la misma empezamos a notar que
se le olvidaban las cosas y aquí en
sinaloa por desgracia tengo muchos
muchos pacientes mujeres sobre todo que
les han matado un hijo y siempre es como
regla que te dice el familiar pues
fíjense que a mi abuelita oa mi mamá o
mi tía que le mataron a su hijo desde
entonces es otra está como irá ya no
quiere saber de nada y ya está olvidando
las cosas en los hombres generalmente
sucede algo distinto a la cuestión
emotiva familiar en los hombres les
afecta muchísimo el trabajo la pérdida
del trabajo la jubilación la quiebra más
que la cuestión amorosa a las mujeres es
la cuestión amorosa
y el hombre cuando se jubila cuando se
retira y no tiene un complemento de vida
generalmente se viene para abajo y puede
presentar síntomas de alzheimer
porque porque esa cuestión de las
emociones resulta que hay una sustancia
que se llama cortisol que se secreta en
el orden los suprarrenales y que es
básica para la vida es la que nos da la
sensación de defensa y nos tienes
atentos y todo esto sin embargo la
secreción inadecuada el cortisol por
mucho tiempo lleva a la gente que vive
en el estrés o en un dolor profundo en
una depresión y que no se trata
dña precisamente el hipocampo la zona
precisa donde se procesa la memoria
reciente de las neuronas de ahí empiezan
a morir y de ahí viene una cascada de
eventos que va a ir evolucionando
esta situación de la elevación del
cortisol no es la única causa de la
demencia se mencionan otros factores por
ejemplo ustedes saben jugadores de
fútbol americano que tienen reciben
muchos golpes en la cabeza como los
boxeadores provoca inflamación cerebral
esos golpes y a la larga pueden tener
alzhéimer que es un factor de riesgo los
golpes sín continuos a la cabeza se
mencionan también anestesias mal
manejadas alguna infección viral
etcétera sin embargo no tenemos
evidencia ni de él ni del diagnóstico ni
de los tratamientos
en todo el mundo existen estos cuatro
medicamentos nada más
qué preguntan ralentizar me encanta la
palabra hacer un poquito más lento el
deterioro de las personas sin embargo
como tristemente sucede en nuestro país
nosotros llevamos a nuestro familiar
como ya está bien ha molado cuando ya no
conoce cuando está bien perdido cuando
está ya muy dependiente y estos
medicamentos no le van a servir de gran
cosa
para poder llegar a aplicar estos
medicamentos hay que hacer un
diagnóstico a nuestro familiar cuando
notemos nosotros que le está pasando a
mi mamá que se están olvidando las cosas
hay que acudir al médico
no le tengas miedo al diagnóstico ve a
que lo chequen a que la chequen porque
porque al inicio de la enfermedad es
cuando podemos utilizar algunas medidas
no solamente farmacológicas y no
farmacológicas donde nos van a retrasar
el proceso de la enfermedad no es lo
mismo padecer demencia a los 60 años que
a los 80 yo digo si a mí me pasa pues
que medie cuando lleve 80 años que no me
acuerdo el nombre de mis hijos y mis
nietos los que lindos pero a los 60 como
vas a dar guerra porque aparte
generalmente están sanos los que tienen
alzhéimer no le duele nada comen muy
bien no vas a resolver las cosas y en la
memoria pero no pierden la inteligencia
eso es muy importante también
comprenderlo para el manejo en la
familia con nuestra familia entonces hay
que hacer exámenes de laboratorio y de
gabinete porque además hay enfermedades
que son curables que semejan una
demencia por ejemplo una persona que
tiene problemas en la tiroides
una persona que tiene un tumor en la
cabeza que puede ser operable
un problema de anemia profunda la baja
de hemoglobina y todo eso
o una deshidratación en un viejito date
cuenta que tiene un alzhéimer profundo
le das a agua lo hidrata es bien y te
levanta conocidad pero ya podemos
encasquetar a nuestro familiar pues él
está como dijo alguien en una
conferencia ya no le sube el agua al
tinaco entonces ya no le funciona y eso
sucede también con las personas que
tienen problemas en el corazón etc
entonces por eso es muy importante
hay algunas gentes me han dicho por para
que lo llevo si de todo el mundo tiene
lucha a como no tiene muchas cosas que
hacerse y además debemos de eliminar las
que si son curables porque con una
pastillita de de una hormona tiroidea
resulta que la gente vuelve a la vida o
si es una depresión le damos una
pastilla un tratamiento adecuado y se
compone la gente entonces es muy
importante una valoración médica de que
esté venimos a la baja a los doctores no
porque pues ahora si mucha gente que no
quiere saber para todos aquellos pero
principalmente para aquellas personas
que tienen algún familiar con demencia
qué pueden hacer prevención es la
palabra
tenemos que prevenir
prevención significa estilo de vida
porque también te dice nada si yo voy a
hacer una dieta de tres meses entonces
voy a comer por las lechugas y tomates y
no no no no
una de tres meses un estilo de vida y
tampoco se trata de que te vuelvas
conejo tienes que comer una comida
adecuada suficiente saludable con un
vinito tinto con tu cafecito con el
chocolatito comer bien evitar la comida
chatarra perdón voy para atrás
evitar la comida chatarra también en vez
de vino tinto pueden tomar un tequilita
si está bien
hay que comer alimentos que contengan
omega 3 como es el pescado antioxidantes
como son las frutas y las verduras y los
probióticos también son muy buenos
porque ahora se sabe que el estómago
tiene mucho que ver con esta cosa de la
cabeza son modas la segunda cosa es
estilo de vida no solamente es comer
bien eliminar la comida chatarra bajarle
a los carbohidratos simples etcétera
sino hacer ejercicio
adelante pero bueno hacer ejercicio es
algo que son los 365 días del año yo
nomás los fines de semana tengo tiempo
pues a ver cómo le haces para que todos
los días te hagas por lo menos 20
minutos de ejercicio para que para que
oxigena tu cerebro para que se muevan
las toxinas para que se ilumine tu tu
mente en tener unas relaciones
familiares perdón
amistades positivas y propositivas aquí
les pasó a estas grandes amigas del
kinder son mis amigas la primera de ella
es la hora de la bbk de fallecer la
semana pasada
en tener este tipo de amistades que te
enriquecen la vida que te llenan de buen
humor de buenas anécdotas es sumamente
importante en la vida relación para
mantener un cerebro sano estamos
hablando de nuestra reparación cerebral
evita las amistades pesimistas y amargas
procura que sean positivas otro factor
importante en las relaciones familiares
sana las si estás peleado con tu hermano
con tu tío con todo él y está desde el
problema eres tú entonces arregla tus
situaciones familiares procura tener
buen humor y arreglar sus conflictos
personales con tus hermanos o con quien
sea otro factor importante es muy
importante
es estimular la mente lo que estamos
haciendo ahorita ya han oído a mis
compañeros que la verdad es que tienen
ideas geniales y están utilizando la
creatividad en una persona que está
tratando de estimular su mente pues
desde hacer sudokus en los crucigramas y
jugar cartas y dominó y todo esto está
muy bien pero si ustedes se salen un
poquito de sus aparatos móviles de su
celular y de sus tablets y demás y van a
ver la naturaleza y empiezan a observar
las puestas de sol los cantos de los
pájaros ya lo mejor se vuelven poetas a
lo mejor agarrar un lienzo y se ponen a
pintar eso es creatividad en estar piel
pega un aparato nomás picándole aquí
como los niños chiquitos que más te
detectan
yo creo todavía no se sabe porque no hay
un estudio serio pero yo creo que esas
personas tienen un alzheimer prematuro
si les vas a que el coco porque no están
pensando lo están haciendo los aparatos
por ustedes entonces hay que estimular
la mente de todas las maneras posibles
cantar bailar escuchar música
lo que se les ocurra va a ser bueno para
tu mente
y muchas cosas más que puedes hacer por
tu vida entonces por qué suceden estas
cosas porque eso que me dices de tener
amigos de salir a la naturaleza de
caminar de alimentarme bien de las
relaciones familiares y no solo eso toda
persona que tiene un sentido de la vida
un poquito lo que vemos de gilberto
ahorita en su revolución humana y de
otros de mis compañeros el hecho de que
tú puedas
saber para qué estás aquí por qué estás
aquí que tengas una actitud de servicio
que no te llenes de egoísmo que
solamente no es para mí de mí para mí
como los chiquitos va a ser que todos
los procesos internos de nuestro
organismo tiene una razón de ser no nada
más porque se les ocurrió a los
psicólogos a los médicos que nos quieren
poner a trabajar mentira eso de la dieta
del ejercicio de la alimentación pues
fíjese que si existe un factor de
crecimiento neuronal que descubrió una
científica italiana premio nobel de
medicina que se llama rita levi
montalcini murió de ciento y cinco años
algo así apenas esa mujer brillantísima
dijo que si se pudiera generar el
cerebro porque no sé si ustedes están
muy jóvenes recuerden que antes se decía
que no había manera de regenerar buena
demostró que sí que un factor de
crecimiento neuronal
y al utilizar todas estas acciones de
servicio de meditación de ver el bien de
los demás de alimentarte bien de hacer
ejercicio y todo lo que mencionamos hace
que se liberen neurotrofinas las
neurotrofinas son sustancias que por
decirlo de alguna manera limpia en el
cerebro entonces lo que estamos haciendo
con estas actividades es simplemente
quitarle la basura al cerebro para que
no se formen esas placas horrorosas de
beta-amiloide etcétera
muy bien entendido y aplicado voy a
hacer todo eso pero qué hago con mi
abuela ya está perdida ánimo que la
ponga hacer sudokus y crucigramas
abiertos no sabe ni qué es eso ya no
sabe de ella no le interesa ni la tele
hay muchas cosas que hacer en primer
lugar vamos a hablar de las de los siete
aces la primera aceptar la enfermedad es
increíble cómo muchos ocultan a su
familiar que está un poco fuera de la
realidad de esta vergüenza que va a
decir la gente ahora ya está un poquito
más abierto pero antes se escondía y se
hacía hasta se amarraban a las gentes no
sensata van prácticamente los cuartos
ahí lo dejaban algo
al buen hacer de la pobre persona no hay
que aceptar que esté enfermo que él o
ella el que lo tenga no tiene la culpa
de lo que le pasa
te puede pasar a ti nos puedes pasar a
cualquiera de nosotros y tienes que
saber que es una enfermedad a largo
plazo que la familia tiene que unirse
para ayudar es muy común también que la
gente te hable por teléfono yo que
estuve trabajando en asilos y todo eso y
ahora no me podrá conseguir un campito
mire es una tía bueno no es tan tía es
una señora de trabajo en la casa no sé
que no le podría comer porque fíjese que
se le va la onda que la gente quiere
deshacerse como si fuera un basurero y
mandar a los dígitos al ácido yo
entiendo que hay casos que son
necesarios pero nosotros tenemos que
aceptar la enfermedad y organizarnos
como familia para poderlo atender en
segundo lugar la atención atenderlo
atender su salud que como les dije bueno
generalmente va a estar sano sin embargo
habrá que llevarlo al médico a sus
revisiones y llevarlo a los centros de
día a los grupos de autoayuda para que
ahí y bueno familiar acuda al grupo de
autoayuda para que ahí platiqué sus
penas y lloré y reniegue iba a encontrar
muy buenas ideas de los compañeros que
están sufriendo lo mismo que ellos
en tercer lugar alimentar ahora se pone
de moda la dieta cetogénica quiere decir
cero carbohidratos imagínense una
persona mayor que ya está bastante ida
de la cabeza que además siempre tienen
hambre
querías pues no puedes comer tamalitos
de chocolate ni dulces y galletas para
que no quieres tener así dale lo que
quiera comer que coma porque además te
acusan de que no les den de comer y
acaba de desayunar porque es otras las
cosas que dicen
que como lo que quiera sobre todo alta
en proteínas porque van a perder mucha
masa muscular se van a debilitar se van
a caer en silla de ruedas etcétera
en cuarto lugar activar que vamos a
activar pues las neuronas que le queden
como les digo no lo vamos a poner a
hacer crucigramas ni a que paren la
computación por supuesto que no pero lo
mejor jugar lotería no va a saber ni qué
ficha pone pero el solo hecho de que son
juegos antiguos se va a divertir un
montón y va a seguir jugando y va decir
lotería llena y esquina cuatro esquinas
y va a querer ganar todo se va a
entretener por lo menos hacer buscar
actividades de acuerdo al grado de
lesión que pudiera tener nuestro
familiar no lo pongas enfrente de una
televisión y prendiera porque no le
interesa si entre más nosotros
estimulamos a nuestro familiar mejor lo
va a ser
ayudar aquí vamos a ayudar al que cuida
hay un fenómeno que se denomina el
colapso del cuidador muchas veces el
cuidador se muere antes que el enfermo
porque son enfermos que duran muchos
años porque se mueren porque se agotan
se colapso generalmente entran en
depresión
están con la pena el dolor no comparten
no tienen ayuda a los hijos no van
porque no yo cómo voy a ver a mi papá de
esa manera no no no yo no puedo
soportarlo yo no voy a verlo porque yo
prefiero acordarse de mi padre cuando
cuando era todo un personaje
ahorita te necesita cuando tú estabas
chiquito se limpiaban la cola y se
bañaba y tú no quieres ir a bañar a tu
papá sino porque que porque yo yo soy
mujer mía papel busco por lo vas a bañar
o ayuda de tu mamá o pone una camiseta
un choripán
el chiste es que hay que ayudar al que
cuida porque si existe verdaderamente
muchas veces se va antes el cuidador que
puede ser la mamá que pues se realiza
soltero típico hay como toda la casa
este como tour en el negocio entonces tú
te quedas de media paja o de mi ama y la
pobre mujer sola pues ahí se queda
todavía más que nada más neurótica
amarte y aparte la dejan sola no le dan
dinero entonces hay que hay que ver la
manera de ayudar a nuestro cuidador
principal
la sexta sería acompañar una persona con
alzheimer o una dimensión como no sabe
qué le pasa si algo tiene terror es a
quedarse solo
nunca lo deje sur ni en la noche si
quiere si lo vas a llevar a caminar que
es muy importante que haya ejercicio
porque si evitas la dependencia a las
sillas de ruedas y esas cosas entre más
camine más ejercicio haga pues menos
discapacidad tiene
a compañeros siempre a comer hacer los
ejercicios tienen paciencia no los
regaños ya te lo dije mil veces mamá y
otra vez la misma pregunta pues
contestaré a las mil veces que te
pregunte o cambiar el chip le digo yo a
los familiares que es cambiar el chip
ahora que se usan esas palabras pues en
vez de que con military y aquí nos viene
tu papá y papá se murió hace 20 años no
hay mamá ya te dije que mi papá se murió
y la viejita llora porque no se acuerda
que se murió
visita a quienes dicen tu papá mamá ya
te dije que mi papá se murió hace 20
años ya fuimos al patio y ahora se le
olvida que murió el señor y cada vez que
le dicen que se murió sufre a lo mejor
la risa
pero en general
no hagas eso yo ya te lo dije pero
después debo olvidar la memoria reciente
en la que se lo olvida pero sin mi amá
estévez insisto cita yo creo que no
tiene eso doctora porque fíjese se
acuerda con la fiesta de 15 años y
cuando se casó y donde puede luna de
miel y que mi papá le compró tal cosa y
no se acuerda que mi hermano la cabecera
de un beso y me pregunta bueno este
hermano tuyo nunca me viene a ver mamá
se acaba de ir memoria reciente
hipocampo eso es lo que se lesiona
primero claro que después no se va a
olvidar se devolverán los recientes y
los anti votos pero en las primeras
fases es muy fácil que las familias se
de stansted como decimos aquí por eso no
y por último lo más importante lo
verdaderamente importante es amar amar a
nuestro familiar pero no solamente hay
si yo lo amo amo a mis padres en cada
momia abuelita con obras si de verdad
nada hay más reparador que sentirse
querido aceptado y cuidado porque si
algo olvida las personas tienen
problemas con la memoria pero lo último
que se pierde hasta antes de morir te es
efectividad el que lo toque es el que lo
trates bien una persona con alzheimer
sabe perfectamente bien que él no te
conozca y tú quién eres
además soy tu hija no auto no eres tú de
dónde vienes pero si tú le hablas con
cariño la papayera sé que a la mejora de
que linda adquirida muchachita y era la
hija pero si tú eres ajena más si no se
tuviese que ver que porque ayer pasa es
que a mí no me quieres si quieres la
fulana propio empieza uno con esas
tonterías con la viejita ves quién sabe
que ser esta bruja
pero si la trata bien no se va acordar
que su hija pero lo decida mira qué
bonita ay qué buena eres o sea si uno
trata bien a estos enfermos
la respuesta es maravillosa y algo se me
pasó que no quiero dejar de decirles de
la música si ustedes a su familiar
así está en la última fase de la
enfermedad que es muy complicada le
ponen unos audífonos y le ponen su
música de su época la canción de agustín
lara las grandes bandas de entonces nos
el jazz lo que le haya gustado en su
vida la música ranchera en lo que sea le
ponen esa música aunque no sean
audífonos pero se la ponen y aunque esté
bebiendo partes y con los ojos volteados
se reconectan se reconectan y en ese
momento probablemente te conozca y pueda
sacarle una palabra o dos coherente es
increíble lo que la música hace en el
cerebro porque son otras vías las que se
estimulan no hay que olvidar pues que el
cerebro tiene múltiples canales para
activarlos hay que ser inteligentes hay
que ser creativos para poder tratar a un
familiar con este tipo de enfermedades y
recuerden
el amor no se olvida y pregúntense si
esto me pasará a mí que me gustaría que
hicieran conmigo gracias
[Aplausos]